new details into the nation's latest
mass shooting
including a clearer picture of the lives
lost
eight people ranging in age from 19 to
74
were killed and five others were injured
when a former employee opened fire at a
fedex facility in indianapolis
late thursday it follows recent
shootings in georgia
colorado and south carolina on friday
president biden described the string of
killings as quote
a national embarrassment as he renewed
his call for congress
to enact gun control reform nikki
batiste is in indianapolis this morning
with the latest nikki good morning
dana good morning well so far
authorities are not saying whether or
not
brandon hold the suspect in this case
knew any of the victims some who were
his former colleagues
here at fedex but they have confirmed
the 19-year-old was interviewed by the
fbi a year ago after his own mother
called the police
in a matter of minutes armed with a
rifle 19-year-old brandon hull shot and
killed
eight people at this fedex facility
where he was once an employee
they have an active shooter currently at
fedex first responders raced to the
chaotic scene
finding the wounded and the witnesses
running for cover
there was no confrontation with anyone
that was there he just appeared to
randomly start shooting hall then took
his own life about one year after an
interview with the fbi
the teen's own mother had reported him
to local police
saying he might try to die by suicide by
cop
authorities say hole was put on an
immediate detention mental health
temporary hold
and a shotgun was taken from his home in
the wake of
another mass shooting president biden
called gun violence in the u.s
an international embarrassment who in
god's name
needs a weapon that can hold
100 rounds or 40 rounds or 20 rounds
it's just wrong and i'm not going to
give up until it's done
but he grew defensive friday when asked
why he is prioritizing infrastructure
legislation
over police reform and gun control i've
never not prioritized this no one has
worked harder to deal with
the violence used by individuals using
weapons than i have
i'm the only one ever to have passed an
assault weapons ban among the victims
were four members of the local sikh
community
raising questions about the possibility
of a hate crime
but the fbi says it did not identify
whole as racially motivated
after speaking with him last year the
youngest victims were both
19 the oldest 74-year-old john
weissert his wife of nearly 50 years
showed us his picture
just before she learned her husband had
died he does his job
starting at 5 30. so that was it i just
said goodbye have a good evening said
that to him a couple days a couple times
and he was gone
nothing since then not a thing not one
word have you tried calling himself
i tried last night during the night but
there was no answer
it is unclear how or when hoe got the
rifle he used here
authorities have not revealed a motive
and say the investigation could go on
for days
five victims with gunshot wounds have
been treated here at local hospitals
jeff nicki thank you